I'm gonna look like Seacrest after this
Ryan Seacrest that's right whoa no
Deborah Seacrest my old neighbor we're
getting face-off I feel like I'm gonna
be a whole new person after this I know
nothing about facials I don't pay
attention to my face I know it's here in
preparation I have not washed my face in
the last week so yeah I did I'm excited
just because I'm really into like my
face yeah I think I'm gonna look
beautiful I'm not gonna look like a baby
one of them just like a little baby face
basically we're gonna wash your skin
with an exfoliant that removes and
loosens up the dead skin and then we're
gonna do an enzyme which actually
dissolves the dead skin and preps the
skin for extractions that look like a
Paolo oh no and this headband do you
have a normal skin care routine oh yeah
if I close my eyes and the steam in my
face kind of feels like a summer breeze
enzymes are like the pac-man of skin
just eating my face but how are you
doing I'm good beauty is pain so I am
just gonna place these on your eyes
that's a good look great look
Oh God Oh God Oh No apologize in advance
[Music]
oh this is wonderful
[Music]
these are cool gloves so they help with
redness inflammation and they tighten
the pores so they're gonna feel really
cold on your skin okay
okay no not that cold Oh dancing little
ice globes dancing across my face and
this is everything that I want forever
[Music]
whoa I'm getting car washed
[Music]
friends like I'm so glad I got this bit
off so everyone can just see oh my god
that is my chest
yeah I feel spectacular it was amazing
it was just so it was a all body
experience is amazing I've never felt
this clean before also my face is sigan
it's like I'm touching somebody else's
face I didn't realize it would be as
relaxing as it was the softest skin I
think I've ever felt in my life I feel
kind of blissed-out
my nose I actually feel like a baby's
butt so you know goal accomplished after
this you know I might do it every every
couple months
[Music]